[موسيقى]
اولا
انا
بشكرك جدا
زي ما هو كده
[موسيقى]
او قيمه الاشياء او او انت انسان لو حطيتي
في مكان الصخر هتبقى ايه
لو في العصر الجميل كده رجعنا لورا خالص
بقينا في اي خدمه هيستخدموه ازاي
يعني كل حد كده يقدر يجاوب معي هيستخدم
الايفون في ايه
لا هو بالنسبه له هو اهتماماته حاجه ثانيه
بس هو شاغل
لقى الاختراع ده موجود فهيستخدمه ازاي
هيعمل ايه ثاني
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في حد عنده قدامه ثانيه
[موسيقى]
عارف
انه ممكن يستخدم كمان
اللي هو ممكن يتجنن ممكن يحصل له حاجه هو
مش هينفع طبعا في حد هزر
[موسيقى]
للاسف هو هيبقى شايفه ممكن يستخدموا
يعني هيستخدمه على حسب الانتاج اللي هو
عايزه ممكن بس فيه زي ما قلنا ان هو هيشوف
ان هو مرايه ممكن يثبت به حاجه ممكن يحطه
زي الثقل الحاجه لان هو وقتها او الوقت
لما شاف الاي فون ده احتياجات وما كانتش
للاي حاجه احتياجات ان هو كل احتياجات
ويعملوا حاجات هاند مين
بيعمله
بيصنعه وجود
هو مش فاهم القيمه بتاعه الايفون ده ايه
هو مش عارف يستخدمه في ايه
عشان كده ممكن نبقى كلنا
نتقابلنا موقف زي ده ممكن
الدراسه معينه واحنا درسناها لمجرد
ان الاهلي عايزين تبقى دكتور او الاهلي
عايزين ان انا ابقى مهندس بس انا احتياجي
انا مش مش عارف انا هعمل ايه ممكن الاقي
نفسي في مكان ثاني خالص
ساعات كلنا بنحط في
مواقف
مش انا يعني مش بيقدر يطلع اللي جواه كم
حد فينا راح وظيفه ما نجحش فيها
[موسيقى]
كل الناس معظم الناس ساعات
بتوع الشغل بتوعي واخلص الشغل عشان اعمل
كريم واعمل فلوس
وابقى شخص موجود في التليفون
لا انا مش عادي وظيفه دي انا هاشتغل في
المجال اللي انا شفته ده بالضبط هو ده
اللي حصل معي انا انا دنيا اشرف دكتوره
العربيات اول اسكندريه
بعد الظهر
اصلا انا قعدت سنه كامله في البيت
مكنتش لاقيه نفسي
كنت باشتغل
خالص بعيد عن اللي انا عايزاه
بالمناسبه كمان همم
ثانويه عامه عشان تبقى مهندس او تبقى
انا ما دخلت ثانويه عامه وانا جبت مجموعه
يعني دخلت مع ده دخلت صبايا
عشان انا كنت شايفه ان انا هاقدر احقق
فيها حاجه
وبعد ما خلصت الصنايع بتاعتي
بدات ان انا
حصلت لي جروب كده في حياتي اقعد خلاص في
البيت وانا مش هينفع انا حامل دراسه ثاني
بعد ما قعدت في البيت لا انا لقيت نفسي ان
انا مش
انا بعض الوضع اللي انا فيه اول خطوه
اخذتها ما كنتش حباه ان انا راجل
[موسيقى]
كانت مقدمه
واحده واحده
بدات ان انا الاقي نفسي بدات ان انا احس
ان انا
احب المدارس جدا بدات ان انا ادور
في المقالب
ودخلت المسابقات وبدات انجح في المجال
بقى يعني بعد كده
حسيت ان انا
مش طريقه
وربنا
علشان كده دايما دايما دور على حاجه اللي
انت بتحبها تدور على الحاجه اللي هتعمل لك
ما تدورش المجتمع دلوقتي هيقول علي ايه او
ما تدورش الناس هتشوفني ازاي انت شايف
نفسك ازاي انت حابب نفسك تبقى ايه
ولما ترسل ما تضايقش متزعلش الفشل ده
بدايه النج
اح اي حد بيبدا يعمل تجربه زي البشمهندس
قالت وجرب كثير جدا
ونجحت في الاخر هي دلوقتي الحاجه
اللي خالد البشمهندس النهارده يقف قدامنا
ويتكلم عن على التجربه بتاعته زي ما انا
كنت فاكره ان انا فشلت اللي انا دخلت
ثانويه
[موسيقى]
بدات تخليني باينه وتخليه
بدال الناس تعرفني بدات الناس ان هي تعرف
مين اللي بتطلع اشرف
ملكش دعوه باي كلام بيخلي الكلام السلبي
دائما ان هو سبب اا السلم بتاعك هو سبب
نجاحك
ما تقعدش بدور وانت الطريق شغفك وطريق
الهدى نظرات الناس انسى خالص بمناسبه ازاي
اقدر اوي اوي اوي كوب اهلك عليك هم في
الاول هتبقى شايفين لو ايه المتهود ان انا
كان بابا شايفني رايحه تعمل ايه
في العربي
[موسيقى]
دائما دور على شبكه ودور على الحاجه اللي
انت اللي انت حاببها ما تدورش الناس
شايفين ازاي او الناس عايزاني اعمل ايه
كلنا ساعات بندور على قيمتنا في شكلنا
كلنا ساعات بندور على على ان احنا لما
نتعلم لغه جديده دور على جواك انت حابب
ايه
يعني كلنا
ممكن حد يقدر يجاوب
تمام في حاجه ثاني
ايه
كلنا شايفين
كلنا شايفين ان الايفون حاجه غاليه قوي او
حاجه لها طين قوي علشان كلنا دائما دلوقتي
اكثر ناس بتدور
على الصور صوره حلوه ان انا اطلع على على
الميديا صوره شكلها مختلف هو حضرتك في اي
كاميرا حلوه قوي فبدا يعلي انت عشان كده
كلنا بندور كل حاجه
فانت برده كده خلي عندك حلمك يبقى هو ده
الحاجه اللي بتبيعك او الحاجه اللي الناس
بتفضل تدور عليها
اتمنى
لو اي حد عندك
[موسيقى]